where's the [ __ ] money man Cayman
Islands
Kieran I mean I've never been in the
Cayman Islands a lot of banks over there
there are you know that when I was being
interviewed by the Secret Service they
were like they were they were saying
because when we when Amanda and I went
to with Italy I had I had like a cap
fall off right and so I needed to go to
a dentist so I left I was like look
while you guys go do this and we were in
Bari and I said well you guys go
shopping I'm gonna go to a dentist so I
go to a dentist and I have them they
like glue the [ __ ] thing back on
right mmm
so when I get picked up the Secret
Service is like listen you know I'm like
what are you talking about there's no
money there she was like you were in you
had multiple passports you were in Bari
and and Amanda told us that you left for
like four or five hours you could have
easily opened up multiple bank accounts
and put the money away in cashier's
checks or whatever and I was like that's
first of all there would be bank
accounts that were being opened by
Americans the u.s. a US would be
notified that you had a bank account in
another country mm-hmm so you know I was
like and then they were like well you
could for all we know you've got a
you've got IDs in other people's names
outside of the country so for all we
know I'm like listen listen stop if you
were smart you would have yeah if I was
smart but I'm not that smart everybody
thinks I'm so sharp I'm not you did a
good job convincing me oh good times
okay this was good this was great thank
you for doing this and thank you I'm
sure I'm speaking for millions of people
on YouTube I'm sure they're all
extremely entertained by this episode
they've been looking for it for a long
time yeah what about the Dateline one oh
we should do that one next yeah but you
gotta get like you know ready you know
what hey you know listen it's twice as
bad as this one is it really it's
[ __ ] it's not one on YouTube because
they actually interview me Oh
um let's see is it will do it will do oh
no it's not it's not
oh no it's nowhere Ivan looked and
looked everybody it might listen I got
an army of guys in the comment section
who have scoured the internet they wish
it was if you could find it they'd have
found it yeah but to get this I had to
get American greed I had to because it
was on Hulu initially when I first got
out then they took like the whole season
down and so I had to contact
NBC I don't know they I to contact the
producers of whatever so you have it
what no for American greed I'll give you
not the Dateline episode oh I'm saying I
can't I had to contact them they wanted
me to give them like 1,100 1,200 dollars
then they came back I was like no no you
don't understand I'm the guy out there
like to license it to you it's this much
Plus every time I was like license it
bro I said I'm the guy in the episode so
then they come back and they okay well
we'll sell you one for $400 or $300 like
what are you talking about
just like you well then I then I explain
I then I explain that listen you've
already given me a copy before I have a
copy they had given me one of my mother
had it and she's lost it and I did this
whole [ __ ] thing that you gabey's
gave me one I had a courtesy copy my
mother moved she lost a copy I just
asking you to replace it I already have
it you've already given it to me for
free so then they came back and they
said okay here's what we'll do we'll
post it and you can will Dow give you
the download so they download and gave
it to me that was it but so somebody
needs to do that for Dateline because
there's there's actually two date lines
one where I'm not interviewed they just
interview Becky you can imagine how that
one comes off then there's a second one
where they interview me still horrible
where this guy the same guy that did the
same narrator same dude same dude cuz
this it's called Curtis productions
mm-hmm he did they do did both of them
so yeah man it was it was horrible too
anyway this was good thank Matt yeah
all right well wait wait wait you got we
got a plug got a plug the one more time
listen bro buy the [ __ ] book it's a
pretty good book okay and the the
youtube channel
it's called inside true crime and it's
got about seven or eight of my stories
plus some supplementary material on
there and audiobooks some of the stories
I've written and then also I have a
website inside true crime calm and
patreon I got patreon and what else
there's other stuff there's Instagram
and all the other jumps yeah yeah all
the typical platforms yeah I'm trying to
figure it out
hey do you know who Bubba the love
sponges yeah he's like one of the most
famous radio shock jock DJ whatever
hosts in Tampa Bay talked to a guy that
like represents him today and I'm he's
supposed to try and hook it up so that I
go on bubble oh he's on um Stritch
twitch he's on twitch I forget how many
million subscribers whatever he's got a
bunch I mean I grew up when I grew what
I was in Tampa yeah bubble us one was
huge okay
oh my said bubble of sponge I was like
the [ __ ] out he was like do you know who
that is I was like of course I know who
I was and he's like look would you be
interested I'm like the awesome bros on
Twitch now he was hilarious
he's I love [ __ ] list him all the
time I mean used to that would be great
so maybe that allow Wow I was his deal
we'll see what do you do he uh he did he
kill a pig on the radio what are you
[ __ ] I think I was I've been I think
they slaughtered a pig on like live
radio and that's one of the reasons a
lot of people didn't like him he got a
lot of heat for that he did a lot of
fucked-up [ __ ] like he had he was kind
of like the stern the Howard Stern of
the South right return was in New York
and he was in Florida he was good he's
still good friends with Howard Stern he
still talks to him on his show I think
yeah yeah that'd be a house run would be
pretty cool that'd be pretty cool to be
on yeah I told you I tell you the Wolf's
den with a bail for God Alford yeah I so
his uh yes that's good that you're
hitting all the all the right damn it
I'm trying I'm trying I don't know yeah
I haven't got a callback I got a couple
yeah a couple emails from his assistant
but you know I haven't heard the fly out
here bro those guys throw you that would
be great you're good content for them
so we're I picked you out of the dirt
you did you're great at this you're
gonna be writing these [ __ ] American
grass and you're tweaking it slowly not
really I emailed you yeah and then you
you conned me yeah I remember when you
said you were like you're like I was
like hey you know I'm thinking about
doing a true-crime podcast and you go
well you know the best way to gauge
whether people would be interested in or
not is for you to come on my show and
tell your story and I was I right or was
I wrong this [ __ ] trying to get
me to [ __ ] come on and you're like
cuz then you know that you go then then
if we were to do the you know then we'll
know and then we could talk about doing
a true-crime podcast and so I did it and
now you're like yeah I just don't know I
don't see any interest there now you're
like where you aren't so busy like where
you are now too busy for me Matt Cox
unbeliev I try to get you an episode of
my floor show and you said and you told
me that kill us
I never I thought what I said it's not
what I said trying to a day-in-the-life
documentary of Matt Cox
listen I'm painting the painting of the
Joker right now I know you told me so
should be filming that yep that's pretty
cool stuff
it is pretty jokes that's pretty cool
everyone wants to see you day in the
life of Matt Cox outside of the studio
bro listen it it starts at like 4:30 or
5:00 yeah let's do it
I get a couple of you know a couple of
couple cups of raw sugars mainline a
couple packets of raw sugars I hit the
gym you know cuz I'm fifty fallen apart
around five miles we could go to my
buddy my buddy's gym Trina let's do it
call - yeah then I compounded go to my
mom's house and I have breakfast with my
mom then he sick we filmed that you had
breakfast here mom everybody's 90 that's
crazy she's 90 and she picks at me that
would be so much fun to film that then
people would love it she does she's it's
always the same thing oh you don't shave
anymore no mom I follow up to the
- the American green you don't have any
collared shirts no I have a mom I just
didn't we're wondering if you don't ever
wear them all right cool well let's do
it thanks again for doing this and
that's a wrap ladies and gentlemen all
right have a nice night everybody